in houston the deshaun watson situation
gets worse instead of better tony busby
the lawyer who
represents now nine women
who will be bringing lawsuits there have
been three filed
and what busby said on instagram today
as we complete our due diligence we will
file the remaining ones in due course we
are talking to several
others uh
we talked about this at length now pft
live and i don't have much to add
to the reality that in this day and age
um if you're not guilty of the things
that
that desean watson is alleged to have
done you are still guilty of putting
yourself in a horrible situation by
going to
women's homes for massages with no
witnesses present
having women come from atlanta to
houston to massage you in your hotel
suite
with no witnesses present because you
are setting up the possibility
that someone is going to accuse you of
doing something you didn't do if he
didn't do anything
even if he's completely clean and it's
just
nine people now making false or
exaggerated claims against him
and and he walks away scot-free when he
defends himself
the mere fact that he allowed himself to
be in these situations where it's an
inherently intimate act
and there's two people present and
there's no way to prove
who's telling the truth later shireen
this was this was a disaster
waiting to happen for deshaun watson
yeah no question mike can you make a
great point there and you know when the
first one came out
it didn't raise a really that big of a
red flag for me but as
the days have gone on and more of these
have come out
there's huge concerns and there's huge
concerns from a houston texas standpoint
of where this goes and for any team
that's interested in training for desean
watson
you're definitely going to want to know
more about this before you give up
your in mortgage or entire future to
trade for a franchise quarterback like
desean watson
and you know there's all sorts of crazy
speculation out there and i want to say
it is crazy speculation there's no
evidence that the texans had any role in
this that they're behind this in any way
no one is
credibly suggesting that and it would be
ludicrous if they did it because if
you'd get caught that's the kind of
thing you
lose your franchise for and how does it
help the texans yes it kills the trade
market
but you do you get to a point where you
can't keep him either
if there's this avalanche of accusations
oh hey we we got hey yeah this is great
we came up with a way to get deshaun
watson to not want to trade now what are
we going to do
with the fact that he's been accused by
nine different people and counting and
now the
nfl as as expected when
cases like this go from one to two to as
many as nine if not more
letter was sent by lisa friel who's in
charge of the nfl's internal
investigations department to tony busby
i became aware of the lawsuits you filed
yesterday
as well as the one you filed this
morning which contained various
allegations of misconduct
i'm writing to let you know the league
is open in investigation into these
allegations and to request
the cooperation of your clients in our
investigation such cooperation would
begin
with engaging in zoom interviews with
myself and another league investigator
at which of course you would be present
see the nfl needs
has so much for confidential being
placed at the top
sorry sorry lisa you sent the letter
to the wrong lawyer there's nothing
confidential or discreet
about tony busby when it comes to this
case or as far as i can tell anything
else
here's the advice that i would have
given desean watson
uh assuming and look i've been lied to
by clients before it's one of the things
i don't miss about practicing law you
get lied to all the time you get lied to
by everybody everybody's got an angle
and you got to be very careful and you
got to develop a good
bs filter but if i was convinced that
deshaun watson
had not done any of the things he had
done my advice to him would have been
settle these cases now make payments now
with a confidentiality agreement and an
agreement that they will not cooperate
with the nfl because nfl has no power
to compel any of these individuals to
talk
so oh i don't want to pay a hundred
thousand dollars to somebody for
something i didn't do
well okay that's fine but it's a cost of
being stupid enough to put yourself in a
situation
where you could be falsely accused you
need to pay that tax
otherwise this whole thing is going to
potentially blow up on you and here we
are sharing just two days after
it all first surfaced it's blown up onto
sean watson
even and again this all assumes he
didn't do it different conversation if
he's guilty
even if he's not it's blowing up and
it's a mess
and it all could have been avoided if he
started writing checks that he's
uniquely
qualified and able to write
and they don't like doing that mike well
let's pull the curtain back you know a
lot of teams have
fixers that go in and fix these things
and pay off people and it goes away
quietly it's just a fact of doing
business it's what happens in the nfl
guilty or not guilty it's the easiest
way to make these things go away without
it but coming out publicly because when
you google these names these things
don't go away whether you're
it doesn't really matter whether you're
innocent or guilty because these things
never go away and people are always
going to remember this no matter what
when you google it it's going to come up
so the easiest way to make it go away is
to pay off the money right
so let's hope mike that he's not guilty
i do hope that
uh but this has got to play out and it's
going to be
uh it's going to be interesting to watch
what happens here and what houston does
and if if there is a trade to happen now
but i don't see a trade happening now
mike
this thing's got to get cleared up first
with a little more clarity
it's going to be harder and harder to
get people to give him the benefit of
the doubt who don't know him who don't
have a vested interest in this i mean i
know him i've been around that doesn't
make him not capable of these things
because
a lot of people surprise surprise act
differently and private
than they act in public but i was
stunned by the first one
but you know hey you're the human
reaction with each additional one you
start thinking man
man and and i'm at the point where it's
just man how stupid if you didn't do it
how stupid to put yourself in these
situations
where you're having these interactions
and it's under the guise of a massage
and
there's no one there an inherently
intimate act and there's no one there
sim said today he got a massage like
that when he was playing his wife was in
the room
to be the witness or or just record the
massage and
save the the file so there can never be
any misunderstanding of what happened in
that room
these are the kinds of steps that a
prudent person needs to engage in to
avoid
exactly what happened and there's a
lesson here to be learned by all
professional athletes
moving forward or anyone in a position
where you could potentially become the
target
for allegations that you did something
you shouldn't have done and again this
all assumes that you engage in behavior
that is proper if you engage in improper
behavior you get what you deserve but
you can still get yourself into
a problem if you always do everything
the proper and appropriate way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports